Ce que je dis ne devrait pas non plus être pris
comme une justification aux violations des droits de l'Homme,
tel que les peines de mort
prononcées en Égypte cette semaine.
Mais ce que je veux dire
est que nous devons défier ces mouvements intégristes musulmans
car ils menacent les droits de l'Homme
dans les contextes musulmans,
et ils le font de plein de façons,
la plus évidente étant les attaques directes sur des civils
par des groupes armés.
Mais cette violence n'est que la partie émergée de l'iceberg.
Ces mouvements alimentent la discrimination envers
les minorités religieuses et sexuelles.
Ils veulent réduire la liberté de religion
de ceux qui soit la pratiquent d'une façon différente
soit choisissent de ne pas pratiquer.
Et plus encore, ils sont à la tête d'une guerre ouverte
contre les droits des femmes.
Face à ces mouvements,
récemment le discours occidental
a le plus souvent offert
deux réponses inappropriées.
La première que l'on trouve parfois à droite
dit que la plupart des musulmans sont intégristes
ou que quoi que soit sur l'Islam est fondamentalement intégriste,
et c'est juste offensant et faux,
mais malheureusement à gauche on rencontre parfois
un discours qui est trop politiquement correct
pour ne serait-ce qu'admettre le problème de l'intégrisme musulman
ou, et c'est encore pire, l'excuse
et c'est tout aussi inacceptable.
Je cherche donc une nouvelle façon
de parler de tout cela ensemble,
qui est basé sur les expériences vécues
et l'espoir des gens qui sont en première ligne.
Je suis tristement consciente
de l'augmentation de la discrimination envers les musulmans
dans des pays comme le Royaume-Uni et les États-Unis,
et c'est aussi une source de grande inquiétude,
mais je crois fermement
que raconter ces histoires contre les stéréotypes,
de gens d'héritage musulman
qui ont fait face à ces intégristes
et ont été leurs victimes premières,
c'est aussi une bonne façon de contrer la discrimination.
Laissez-moi vous présenter
4 personnes dont j'ai eu l'honneur
de raconter l'histoire.
Faizan Peerzada et l'atelier théâtral nommé
comme son père, Rafi Peer,
promeuvent depuis des années les arts
de la scène au Pakistan.
Avec l'émergence de la violence djihadiste,
ils ont reçu des menaces
afin d'annuler leurs événements, menaces auxquelles ils n'ont pas cédé.
Et donc ils ont été frappés par un poseur de bombes en 2008 à Lahore
à la 8ème édition du festival mondial d'arts de la scène,
produisant une pluie de verre
qui est tombée sur le lieu
blessant neuf personnes,
et plus tard cette nuit-là,
les Peerzada ont pris une décision difficile :
ils ont annoncé que leur festival
continuerait comme prévu le lendemain.
Comme Faizan disait : « Si nous
nous prosternons devant les islamistes
ce serait comme être assis dans le noir. »
Ils ne savaient pas ce qui allait se passer.
Est-ce que les gens viendraient ?
En fait, des milliers de personnes sont venues le lendemain
à Lahore pour soutenir les arts de la scène,
et cela a, dans le même temps, ravi
et terrifié Faizan,
et il est allé voir une femme
qui était venue avec ces deux jeunes enfants,
et il lui a dit : « Vous savez qu'il y avait une bombe ici hier,
et vous savez qu'il y a une menace ici. »
Et elle a dit : « Je le sais,
mais je suis venue à votre festival
avec ma mère quand j'avais leur âge,
et j'ai toujours ces images en tête.
Nous nous devons d'être ici. »
Avec un public tellement fidèle,
les Peerzada ont pu terminer
leur festival selon le programme.
Et puis l'année suivante,
ils ont perdu tous leurs sponsors
à cause des risques de sécurité.
Quand je les ai rencontrés en 2010,
ils étaient au milieu du premier événement
qu'ils ont pu organiser au même endroit,
et c'était le 9ème festival d'arts de de la scène de la jeunesse
tenu à Lahore une année où la ville
avait déjà souffert de 44 attaques terroristes.
C'était un temps où les talibans pakistanais
avaient commencé leur ciblage continu
des écoles pour filles et qui culminerait
avec l'attaque de Malala Yousafzai.
Qu'est-ce qu'ont fait les Peerzada dans cet environnement ?
Ils sont mis en scène des pièces de théâtre par ces écoles de filles.
J'ai eu le privilège de voir « Naan Wal »,
qui était une comédie musicale en Punjabi.
Les fillettes de l'école primaire de Lahore
en jouaient toutes les parties :
elles dansaient, elles chantaient,
elles jouaient la souris et le buffle,
et j'ai retenu mon souffle, me demandant :
« Arriverons-nous à la fin
de cet incroyable spectacle ? »
Et quand nous y sommes arrivés, tout le public
a soufflé,
et quelques personnes ont pleuré,
et ensuite ont rempli l'auditorium
de l'explosion pacifique de leurs applaudissements.
Je me souviens avoir pensé à ce moment-là
que les poseurs de bombes firent les gros titres
deux ans auparavant
mais que cette soirée et ces personnes
étaient une histoire aussi importante.
Maria Bashir est la première et seule
femme procureur général en Afghanistan.
Elle est en poste depuis 2008
et a ouvert un bureau pour enquêter sur
des cas de violence contre les femmes
qui représentent le domaine le plus important
de son mandat.
Quand je l'ai rencontrée à son bureau à Herat,
elle est entrée, entourée de
quatre hommes larges avec quatre gros pistolets.
En fait, elle a maintenant 23 gardes du corps, car
elle a survécu à des attentats
qui ont presque tué ses enfants,
et ont fait perdre une jambe à un de ses gardes.
Pourquoi continue-t-elle ?
Elle dit avec un sourire que c'est la question
que tout le monde pose --
comme elle le dit : « Pourquoi risquez-vous de ne pas vivre ? »
Et pour elle c'est simplement
qu'un meilleur futur pour toutes les Maria Bashir à venir
vaut le risque, et elle sait
que si les gens comme elle
ne prennent pas ce risque,
il n'y aura pas de meilleur futur.
Plus tard durant l'interview,
la procureur Bashir m'a dit qu'elle était inquiète
quant à l'issue possible
des négociations du gouvernement avec les Talibans,
les gens qui ont essayé de la tuer.
« S'ils entrent au gouvernement,
dit-elle, qui protégera les droits des femmes ? »
Et elle appelle la communauté internationale
à ne pas oublier ses promesses faites aux femmes
parce que maintenant elle veut la paix avec les Talibans.
Quelques semaines après mon départ,
je vis un titre sur internet.
Un procureur afghan a été assassiné.
Je cherche désespérément sur Google,
et heureusement j'ai découvert
que la victime n'était pas Maria,
mais malheureusement, un autre procureur afghan
est mort par balles en allant au travail.
Et maintenant, quand j'entends des nouvelles pareilles,
alors que les troupes internationales
commencent à quitter l'Afghanistan,
nous devons continuer à nous intéresser à
ce qui arrive aux gens là-bas,
à toutes les Maria Bashir.
Parfois, j'entends toujours sa voix dans ma tête
qui dit, sans bravade ni rien :
« La situation des femmes en Afghanistan
sera un jour meilleure.
Nous devrions en préparer les fondations,
même si nous sommes tués. »
Il n'y a pas de mots adéquats
pour dénoncer les terroristes d'al Shabaab
qui ont attaqué Westgate Mall à Nairobi
le jour-même de la compétition de cuisine des enfants
en septembre 2013.
Ils ont tué 67 personnes, dont des poètes et des femmes enceintes.
Loin de cela, dans le Midwest américain,
j'ai pu rencontrer des Somaliens américains
qui travaillaient pour contrer les efforts d'al Shabaab
pour recruter un petit nombre de jeunes
de Minneapolis
afin de prendre part dans des atrocités comme Westgate.
Burhan Hassan, un étudiant de 17 ans,
neveu d'Abdirizah Bihi,
a été recruté ici en 2008,
envoyé en Somalie
et ensuite tué quand il a essayé de rentrer chez lui.
Depuis, M. Bihi,
qui dirige le Centre d’Éducation et de Défense de la Somalie,
donne de la voix pour dénoncer le recrutement
et les échecs du gouvernement
et les institutions somali-américaines
comme le centre islamique d'Abubakar As-Siddiq
où il croit que son neveu a été radicalisé
durant un programme pour jeunes.
Mais il ne fait pas que critiquer la mosquée.
Il s'attaque au gouvernement
sur ces échecs à faire plus
pour éviter la pauvreté de sa communauté.
Étant donné son propre manque de moyens,
M. Bihi doit se montrer créatif.
Pour contrer les efforts d'al Shabaab
visant à entraîner plus des jeunes désœuvrés,
à la suite de l'attaque du groupe en 2010
sur les spectateurs de la Coupe du Monde en Ouganda,
il a organisé un tournoi de basket du Ramadan
à Minneapolis, en réponse.
Un nombre record d'enfants somali-américains est venu
faire du sport
malgré la fatwa qui l'interdisait.
Ils ont joué au basket
comme Burhan Hassan ne le fera plus jamais.
Pour ses efforts, M. Bihi a été ostracisé
par la direction du Centre Islamique d'Abubakar As-Siddiq,
avec lequel il avait de bonnes relations.
Il m'a dit : « Un jour, j'ai vu l'imam à la télé
nous traitant d'infidèles et disant :
« Ces familles essayent de détruire la mosquée. » »
C'est à l'opposé
de ce que Abdirizak Bihi pense
de ce qu'il essaye de faire
en exposant le recrutement d'al Shabaab,
c'est-à-dire sauver la religion que j'aime
d'un petit nombre d'extrémistes.
Je voudrais maintenant raconter une dernière histoire,
celle d'une Algérienne de 22 ans étudiante en droit,
Amel Zenoune-Zouani,
qui avait les mêmes rêves d'une carrière dans le droit,
que ceux que j'avais dans les années 90.
Elle a refusé d'abandonner ses études
malgré le fait que les intégristes
qui se battaient alors en Algérie
menaçaient tous ceux qui continuaient leurs études.
Le 26 janvier 1997, Amel a pris le bus
à Alger, où elle étudiait,
pour rentrer chez elle, pour passer une soirée
du Ramadan avec sa famille,
et elle ne termina jamais ses études de droit.
Quand le bus entra la banlieue
de sa ville natale, il fut arrêté
à un point de contrôle dirigé par des hommes
du Groupe Islamiste Armé.
Portant son sac de cours,
Amel fut sortie du bus
et tuée dans la rue.
Ceux qui l'ont égorgée
ont ensuite dit à tout le monde :
« Si vous allez à l'université,
le jour viendra où on vous tuera tous
comme cela. »
Amel est morte à exactement 17h17,
nous le savons parce que quand elle est tombée dans la rue
sa montre s'est cassée.
Sa mère me l'a montrée,
avec la deuxième aiguille toujours
optimiste, tendant
vers un 17h18 qui ne viendrait jamais.
Avant de sa mort,
Amel a dit à sa mère en parlant d'elle
et de ses sœurs :
« Rien ne nous arrivera, Inch Allah, si Dieu le veut,
mais si quelque chose se passe,
tu dois savoir que nous sommes mortes pour la connaissance.
Toi et père devez tenir vos têtes hautes. »
La mort d'une si jeune femme est insondable, et
quand je faisais mes recherches,
je me suis retrouvée à chercher à nouveau l'espoir d'Amel
dont le prénom veut même dire « espoir » en arabe.
Je crois que je l'ai trouvé en deux endroits.
Le premier est le courage de sa famille
et de toutes les autres familles qui racontent leurs histoires
et continuent à vivre leurs vies malgré le terrorisme.
En fait, la sœur d'Amel, Lamia, a dépassé son chagrin,
a fait des études de droit,
et pratique aujourd'hui en tant qu'avocate à Alger,
un fait possible parce que
les intégristes
ont connu une large défaite dans le pays.
Et le second endroit où j'ai trouvé l'espoir d'Amel
est dans chaque endroit où les hommes et les femmes
continuent de défier les djihadistes.
Nous devons, en l'honneur d'Amel, soutenir
tous ceux qui continuent la lutte pour les droits de l'homme,
comme le Réseau de Femmes Vivant Sous les Lois Musulmanes.
Ce n'est pas assez, comme me l'a dit Cherifa Khedda,
défenseur des droits des victimes,
ce n'est pas assez de se battre contre le terrorisme.
Nous devons également défier l'intégrisme,
parce que l'intégrisme est l'idéologie
à la source du terrorisme.
Pourquoi est-ce que des gens comme elle, comme chacun d'entre eux
ne sont pas plus connus ?
Comment se fait-il que tout le monde connaisse Oussama Ben Laden
et que si peu connaissent ces personnes
qui résistent aux Ben Laden dans d'autres contextes ?
Nous devons changer cela, et donc je vous demande
de partager ces histoires
parmi vos réseaux.
Regardez encore la montre d'Amel Zenoune,
figée pour toujours,
et regardez maintenant votre propre montre
et décidez qu'il est temps de s'engager
à soutenir les personnes comme Amel.
Nous n'avons pas le droit de garder le silence
parce que c'est plus simple
ou parce que la politique occidentale a aussi des défauts,
parce que 17h17 arrive encore
pour trop d'Amel Zenoune
dans des endroits comme le nord du Nigéria
où les djihadistes tuent encore des étudiants.
Le moment de parler pour soutenir tous ceux
qui défient pacifiquement l'intégrisme
et le terrorisme dans leurs propres communautés,
c'est maintenant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)